before gyome was a demon slayer and
hashira he lived with nine children who
were orphans and raised them in a temple
the area was well known for demon
attacks so gyome had always burned
wisteria incense to ward off any demons
that would harm him and the children one
night one of the nine children disobeyed
the temple rules and traveled beyond its
borders he is immediately attacked by a
demon and in order to save his own life
he tells the demon to eat the other
children as well as gyome after night
fell the child invited the demon into
the temple after putting out the
wisteria incense four children were
immediately killed by the demon and the
remaining children insisted on escaping
the temple ignoring gyome's orders to
stay with him his frail stature and
blindness fueled the distrust the
children had in gyome's ability to
protect them which led them to abandon
him and ultimately get killed by the
demon in the end only one child the
youngest scio had listened and stayed
behind in fear of the demon though it is
unknown how the exchange went down
gyoume had been cut across his forehead
by the demon but soon reversed the
situation and began attacking the demon
mercilessly after realizing he had a
frightening amount of power he went on
and beat the demon's head until the sun
arose soon after people came to the
scene of the incident to help but due to
a misunderstanding the villagers thought
that gyome had killed the children and
not the demon he was later imprisoned
and charged with the murder of the seven
children but kagaya ubu yashiki
intervened and released him before he
could be executed later on gyome became
a demon slayer and after only two months
the stone hashira when tonjiro and
zenitsu arrive at gyome's training camp
in the mountains they are shocked to
find all the trainees including enos
game meditating under a waterfall they
turn around as gyome greets them and are
shocked to see him standing tiptoe on
burning ground while balancing logs and
boulders on his shoulders he explains
that his training consists of only three
things training underneath the waterfall
carrying three logs on one's shoulders
and pushing a large boulder through a
nearby town inosuke who had passed out
underneath the waterfall and had been
resuscitated by tanjuro noted that he
could sense that gyome is the strongest
demon slayer entendro agreed with this
stating that the stone hashira was the
only one with a different scent from the
others gyome is later seen pushing a
giant boulder even bigger than the one
the trainees were supposed to use the
training was quite difficult but also
not compulsory which meant quite a few
of the trainees quit midway left aghast
at the effort required genya then
reveals to tanjuro that the chant
guilleme repeats often is in fact a
series of repetitive actions designed to
maximize his focus and allow him to pull
off feats such as pushing the boulders
later on when tantro successfully
completes the stone hashira training he
is left severely dehydrated yom may
pours water on him to save the boy he
then continues on and says that due to
completing his training and for his
actions in the swordsmith village of
prioritizing the villagers over his
sister he believes tonjiro is a true
swordsman however tonjero states that
the choice was made by nezuko and not
himself and thus he could not accept
gyome's approval upon seeing this the
stone hashira is left further impressed
at tanjro's honesty with all his doubts
now gone gyome states that he has fully
accepted tanjuro regardless of what the
other hashira may say
after receiving information that muzon
has appeared gyome hurried to the ubu
yashiki residence yomei is there to
provide backup to tamayo after she
successfully injects muzon with her
medicine and cleaves the demon's head
clean off yeome mournfully remembers the
first time he met kagaya when he was
only 18 years old and kagaya told him
that he knew gylme was not a murderer
but had fought to protect the other
children at his monastery he then
remembers when kagaya requested that he
be used as a decoy to allow gyome to
behead muzon also telling the stone
hashira that he believed the sun was the
only way to defeat the demon as muzon
regenerates his head and uses his blood
demon art to attack gyome the stone
hashira counters with a stone breathing
third form to protect himself he is then
transported inside the infinity castle
alongside the other demon slayers inside
the castle gioma is with muichiro at
first and the both of them sliced
through a myriad of weaker demons with
ease after being prodded by the miss
tashira yeome confirms that kagaya had
intended to use himself as bait after
his illness had worsened to its final
stages showing great rage at the passing
of their leader later somewhere in the
infinity castle tsunemi is fighting
against upper moon one kokushiba as the
dust from the fight clears so nemi is
nowhere to be seen and gyome states that
the demon slayer core will never stop
until all demons are eradicated from the
world he immediately tells sanemi to
stitch his stomach wound and to stay out
of the fight until he finishes kokoshibo
accesses the transparent world to see
gyome's structure and says that he is
the greatest swordsman he has fought in
three centuries jomei keeps swinging his
flail to gain more momentum and strikes
it onto the ground where the demons
stood as kokushibo dodges the spiked
flail the chains surround his neck and
kokoshibo tries to cut the chains with a
sword but fails as the chains nearly
closed kokoshibo ducks down and they
only catch a small strand of hair
kokoshibo states that gyome's weapon is
made of pure iron and that is an
extremely high grade weapon on the other
hand kogoshibo's sword is made out of
his own flesh so if he tries to cut the
chains his sword will burn out before
cutting it kokoshibo even implies that
iron that absorbs sunlight to that
extent wasn't discovered during the
sengoku era when the swordsmithing
techniques were believed to be at their
peak both kokushibo and gyome used their
respective breathing styles and collide
with the moon breathing and stone
breathing after the clash kokoshibu
states that when his sword breaks it'll
regenerate immediately thus making all
of his attacks completely pointless and
useless yomei however does not care in
the slightest he crosses his arms and
reveals that he managed to awaken his
demon slayer mark
kokoshibo starts to pity him to the
stone hashira's confusion kokoshibo
enters the transparent world once again
stating that gyome's age is around 27.
he then explains that those who awaken
their demon slayer mark will die before
they reach the age of 25 he says that
despite the mark increasing one's power
it also significantly shortens one's
lifespan and according to him yome will
surely die by the end of the night
fukushima praises gyome for mastering
the stone breathing style but also
states that it's sad that all those
magnificent forms will disappear now
that he awakened his mark he questions
giome if he also believes that it's
tragic to which he disagrees yomei
elucidates that that information is old
news and is outdated he continues by
saying that due to him being a member of
the demon slayer core there is no
guarantee that he would see tomorrow
even if he didn't awaken his mark gilmay
finally demands that kokoshibu not
promote his moronic notions to others
along with him reminding kokushibo that
there was a marked individual who lived
past the age of 25 angered by the demon
underestimating his resolve yegin
engages the upper rank meanwhile sanemi
who was able to patch up his torso
injuries also awakens his demon slayer
mark and enters combat with gyome yome
and tsunemi work very well together and
also managed to land some very serious
blows on the demon kokoshibo praises the
hashira even more due to their
coordinated assaults despite them
utilizing different breathing styles it
is also revealed that since guilleme is
blind he uses the rattling echoes of his
chain to determine his opponent's
position the demon slayer combined their
attacks managing to tear off kokoshipo's
kimono however the two are suddenly
injured by a mysterious attack the demon
mocks them saying that ripping clothes
can't kill even an infant before
revealing his sword's hidden power the
ability to extend and branch its own
blades sundemi and gyome barely escaped
the onslaught with sanemi losing his
index and middle fingers in the process
kokoshibo continues his relentless
assault launching consecutive attacks
towards the two hashiro with his moon
breathing with gyome concerned that the
upper rank's reach has increased even
further along with the speed of his
attacks as the battle rages on the stone
hashira eventually realizes that the
demon's eyesight is unnatural and that
he can somehow predict the demon
slayer's movements in a moment of
concentration he sees through
kokoshibo's body realizing that he's
entered the same transparent world as
the upper rank allowing him to perceive
kokoshibo's movements and techniques
with this new development the trio
collectively charged at kokoshipo aiming
to use their newfound advantage and
execute the demon quickly
the upper rank attempts to cut them all
down at the same time using his moon
breathing but they managed to dodge the
swings and close the gap giome distracts
kokoshibo's attention allowing sanemi to
approach with his wind breathing
stunning the demon and allowing gilmay
to rip his right arm off with his flail
kokoshibo notices the approaching mr
shira and attacks him managing to sever
the demon slayer's leg but not before
being impaled in the stomach with his
nakiran sword unfortunately for the
humans the upper rank's head is still
intact after the barrage the demon
attempts to finish off the trio with the
moon breathing but suddenly genya
emerges from the shadows now fully
transformed into a demon and fires his
mutated nature and gun at kokoshibo as
kokoshibo gazes at kenya's new
appearance the bullets that punctured
kokoshibo's skin transform into a large
wooden tree constricting him to the
ground and protecting muichiro from his
attacks gyome takes this opportunity to
engage kokoshiba once again with the
demon realizing that he is in great
danger genya realizes that his bullets
are still within kokoshiba's flesh and
wanting to save everyone he unleashes
his blood demon art blood roots another
tree root comes out of the upper ranks
back and he attempts to use his moon
breathing technique to finish genya off
but without success yeome takes the
opportunity to land his spiked flail on
top of the upper moon's head attempting
to crush it this however is not the case
as kokoshiba's skull withstands the
blunt attack of gyome's flail he then
swings his axe upwards to cut
kokoshibo's neck but the demon blocks it
with his flesh sword muichiro manages to
turn his blade bright red and it reminds
kokoshibo of his younger brother's sword
he thinks to himself how the current
teshira generation is extraordinary
sonemy swings his blade at gyome's flail
in order to give it more momentum but
unintentionally both our weapons begin
to turn red as well with these new
weapons they are capable of bypassing
the upper rank's durability and
regeneration thus finally beheading
kokoshibo
to the horror of all the demon slayers
kokoshibo's head starts to regenerate
yeome and tsunemi continue to attack the
demon but the upper rank swiftly dodges
their attacks kokoshibo is revealed to
have drastically changed an appearance
he has two horns protruding out of his
head and multiple hooks that were once
the blades emerging from his body
tsunami sees the upper rank's head fully
regrown in panics as seemingly all their
efforts were in vain yomi tells him to
keep pressing the upper rank as his body
must be more fragile than it was before
meanwhile kokoshibo is disgusted by his
new appearance and he questions
everything he has done up to this point
memories of his younger brother and his
past overwhelm him to the point that he
gives up this gives giome the chance to
engage and finally behead kokoshibo once
and for all after the upper moon is
defeated tsunami is still sprinting in
random directions and swinging his sword
gyome grabs him and yells that the
battle is over and the upper rank 1 is
dead tsunami goes completely limp in
guilleme's arms after hearing his
explanation yome is surprised how
sonnemy lost consciousness and still
fought the upper rank and lays him down
on the ground yeome comes within genya's
vicinity and points out to muichiro's
mutilated body he states that without
both his and kenya's help they would
stand no chance of beheading the upper
rank with him shedding tears gyome
closes muichiro's eyes and vows to
complete their mission to defeat muzon
sundami screeches and shouts genya's
name in mental agony not wanting to
believe that his brother is really gone
yo may interrupt sunemi's grieving
telling him that the night isn't over
and that muzan kibutsuji still has to be
defeated
at the battlefield chandra is close to
death and the hashira's are getting
slashed and cut by muzon's attacks
mitsuri gets the worst of muzon's
barrage and just as she was about to get
impaled by one of muzon's armed
tentacles a sudden impact destroys that
tentacle saving mitsuri it soon turns
out to be gyome coming to everyone's
surprise especially the demon kings as
muzon comments to himself that gyome is
the one who has defeated his right-hand
man kokoshibo muzon's attacks keep
getting fiercer adding more pressure
onto the hasheras yomi even points out
that without transparent world it is
nearly a gamble to be able to dodge the
demon king's attacks yomi tries to
re-enter the transparent world by
listening for echoes from the demon
lord's body just like he did against the
upper rank 1. he succeeds and visualizes
multiple hearts and brains throughout
the demon lord's body despite the
overall complexity of organs and their
functions the demon lord was still able
to create multiple same organs thus
explaining him being able to survive
decapitation so easily what's even more
interesting they don't have a fixed
location as they always move around
making them incredibly difficult to hit
however he tries to make the most of the
situation and aids others by helping
them access the transparent world as
well yomi manages to turn his weapon red
once again and lands a significant hit
on muzon completely tearing a part of
his body however the tide of the battle
quickly changes as muzon performs his
special attack defeating all demon
slayers at the same time as giome
regains consciousness he witnesses
tanjuro and his fellow demon slayers
pinning muzana into a corner seeing that
the sun is about to rise muzan panics
and transforms himself into a giant baby
trying to escape from the battlefield
despite all the combined attacks on the
demon king it doesn't stop him from
trying to escape into the ground gyome
puts his chain around muzon's neck and
tries to pull him away with the help of
the other demon slayers stopping him
from digging any deeper into the ground
being unable to escape from the sun in
any way the demonic infant wails and
balls as it finally disintegrates thus
the demon lord muzan kibutsuji is
finally dead and defeated forever
at near-death state gyome sees an image
of his orphaned friends that he raised
in the temple with saddened looks in
their eyes they apologized to gyome for
what happened the night the demon
attacked them gyome feeling overwhelmed
starts crying and apologizes for not
being able to protect them they all hug
him and tell him that they have been
waiting for him all this time with
gilmay finally dying in peace
check out this video where we explain
the entire story of zenitsu agatsuma
trust me it's an excellent video